he's Rick Stroud the Buccaneers reporter
for the Tampa Bay Times columnist who
joins us on the program was that an
official workout yesterday Rick by the
Buccaneers not I wouldn't official Dan
you know the back story that is
operation Shoeless Joe Jackson as you
know is what we called it and I met my
reporter and photographer we put on the
black jumpsuits and ski masks it was
just a good old-fashioned stakeout I
mean it had been out there for a couple
weeks that they were working out in the
local high school it was just hard to
get advantage so we knew it was
happening and good for us we got got the
pictures is it legal I mean you're open
Florida's open for business so this
isn't an issue is this an issue with the
NFL it doesn't seem to be at least
yesterday I mean here's the key right
the state opened a little while ago but
if you listen to I've known about it
since before Mother's Day and cam Brady
who was interviewed by Alex Colome on
his doctor one day a lightening floored
said that he'd been working out with
Brady for a couple weeks I mean
virtually so who's just you know how
long this has gone on as far as that
goes the state was open so they're good
with it what's the reaction to Brady
working out well I mean I think people
are surprised but you know we haven't
seen the guy reading stories about him
going in parks and getting kicked out
first time we've actually seen him
wearing a Buccaneers helmet the old
creamsicle of non-contact jersey and and
out there throwing to real Buccaneers
players so I think people expected this
and you know watching him work you can
see just how how precise he is you know
walking guys through routes telling
exactly where he wants them to be and it
was a pretty well organized practice for
about two hours
no Grunk sighting yet not in not in
practice anyway I mean I was in Florida
I think he's mom lives in Fort Myers but
who's to say he could have been out
there other days this is not the first
day so we've now run across him just yet
if I would have told you a year ago
you're gonna be staking out a high
school Rick and Tom Brady is going
to be coming out in a Buccaneer helmet
you would have said what I said you know
they got rid of me because I was
hallucinating I mean this just doesn't
happen yeah we can't have nice things
and yet there he was right and so I mean
this is a franchise it has someone
forgotten playoffs in 12 years 387
winning percentage and yet he's gonna
try to do something this hard I mean
he's gonna try to do something that
peyton manning did in denver it's not
easy and he's got to learn a bunch of
new teammates and the new offense and I
wouldn't get too ahead of ourselves
because Northern Saints are pretty good
in this division you know I'm just
trying to handicap this and and of
course we've talked and I said I'm all
in on the Buccaneers I was all in on
them if Teddy Bridgewater went there I
thought they were gonna be a playoff
team I
we know Brady can handle the pressure I
want to know about the other players on
the team because now you're expected to
do something not we hope you do
something we're expecting you how
different is that going to be for this
young team yeah I think it's gonna be
really different I mean the standard
changes right at these guys we're going
to get up and go to the beach with their
girlfriends instead of working out well
now they're not going to do that I mean
they found out just in the walkthroughs
that he's had with them and the
practices that it's a different level
and you're on national TV five times
that's happened here never and so you
know I think that that's gets your
attention as well so they do have a good
nucleus of football players you know
this was a team that was seven and seven
at one point and then quarterback we
know through through a lot of games away
the defense got better so they should
have high expectations they've got if
Jameis Winston throws 30 touchdowns and
he throws eight interceptions who's the
quarterback for the Buccaneers dish or
not I mean I think it's Jameis Winston I
mean I think you'd still you know
consider Brady and and Philip Rivers and
all those guys but at that point that's
what you hope for when you sign them
right in the playoffs number one and
they have won a couple playoff games so
I don't think we're having that
conversation certainly not
right now playing for a million dollars
I can tell you that I'll leave you with
this Rick these if this season doesn't
start on time they're talking about
maybe those first four weeks now go to
the back end of the schedule I'm just
curious about the availability of the
Super Bowl hotel rooms and all of that
at that time like at the end of February
early March is that going to be any
issue there in Tampa hosting the Super
Bowl well it could look they've got
alternative dates the problem is you
can't go to those hotels right now and
say hey you know keep this weekend open
and that weekend open if they have to
move the schedule back they'll deal with
it then but I'm sure that there's got a
lot of partners here the hotels and
restaurants that'll that'll do
everything they can to make those rooms
available and you know they'll find a
way to keep people keep people fed and
housed I'm sure are you going back to
practice again with Brady or was that
just a one and done what I hear from the
[Laughter]
but they weren't too happy with that
whole thing but it was legal all right
thank you Rick Rick Stroud covers the
Buccaneers for the Tampa Bay Times